le renard lui via les animaux et les
hommes en dvd la blessure il n'y a pas
un mot plus haut que l'autre côté
normand sait que des allusions et
pourtant ça marche très bien
royal vvd ya la scène est en tournée en
france jusqu'en juin 2004 jean-marie
bigard et le 18 juin 2004 j'étais en
arrière de gare et le stade de france
c'est énorme
52 mille paires de faire un appel un oui
c'est ça c'est pour ça qu'on a pris le
18 juin c'est que l'olympia c'est 2000
bercy c'est quoi 15000 à peu près de
13000 être agile 1
la c5 compte 2050 dit je veux faire 5 en
2010 dont 5 en 2010 je me suis mis c'est
le alors il ya des écrans géants
évidemment parce qu'il faut que tout le
monde voit ses écrans gemballa n'ont pas
beaucoup on a beaucoup avancé et sur le
sur le son et ça va être certainement
super et ça c'est un bordel immense
il va y avoir des il y aura déjà des
écrans on va décaler l'image l'image
fait différé de trois ou quatre images
et le sang tout le monde aura le sont à
40 mètres donc tout le monde entendre le
son en même temps et un peu de décalage
ni avec l'image n'y avait que de la
lumière est plus rapide que le sens et
sa wii et 300 mille kilomètres selon des
leçons 346 m seconde et ça pose des
réels problèmes de synchro sports plein
de trucs dans cette émission serious
homme qui a fait la chorégraphie non
mais ça va être énorme au pourquoi
personne n'a jamais réussi à faire ça
parce que tu avais vendu hélas non
sur les ventes de glaces mais c'est que
justement personne ne s'est penché sur
la technique du son etc york 2 1 dans un
stade par exemple tu peux pas faire
faire ça aux gens c'est impossible
un décalage de trois quart de seconde
d'un bout à l'autre c'est très très
difficile de faire taper dans les mains
les gens en même temps et donc
donc c'est pour ça que ça fait une
bouillie infernale et tout mon ami jean
jacques goldman m'a dit écoute moi je
les fais cinq fois en c1 trois failles
gianni deux fois avec céline dion
mais si c'était un cauchemar un
cauchemar total et encore quand on
change les gros concerts comme ça d'
aller retour dans l'est dans les
oreilles
donc en fait de mon bas toi tu tu as ton
retour tu seras tu chantes ton truc toit
tandis que moi je fais et gnagnagna les
gens pour moi et moi je refais gnagnagna
polyvalent que ça va aller retour et je
paierai pas là les parce que tout le
monde aura le son en même temps je
paierai juste le temps du rire du retour
ce qui sera très très très très jouable
et en plus il va tenir trois mois et là
c'est fort jean-marie ça va coûter
combien aux contribuables cette histoire
ça va absolument rien coûté justement
aux contribuables ça va me coûter à moi
de l'argent c'est sûr ouais c'est
évidemment ni de subventions ni de match
a dit on il faut savoir que quand tu
fais à saïda gratuit par exemple si tu
dis si tu joue gratuitement sur les
champs-elysées ça coûte de l'argent tu
me montres enseigne roi sans que ça
coûte aux contribuables
c'est ça coûte combien quand on fait un
spectacle gratuit à paris ça coûte
combien
six mille cinq cent mille personnes sur
les champs-elysées s'écoute 40 millions
de francs au contribuable au parisien
ouais c'est bien tu vois le maire de
bari guide y aura offrir le spectacle
arrive à l'offrir oui on va le payer
quand même vrai qu'ils ont payé leur
place
oui c'est ça c'est comme si débit via
internet évidemment pas c'est très
important de dire ça c'est moi non
seulement c'est une grande fête
je veux faire ça va me coûter
certainement la peau du cul parce que la
technique du son pour la mettre en place
et faire les essais ça va sûrement coûté
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent mais je m'en
fous toi c'est une fête le premier bris
de place est à 15 euros la visite du
stage des 10 euros
donc c'est vraiment une fête pour faire
la der des ders comme je fais d'habitude
donc je vais m'amuser a juste à rentrer
dans le guiness et à faire ça et précis
et quelqu'un d'autre qui veut s'y
frotter à y aller mais en tout cas après
moi j'aurais pu comme laisser glisser
tranquillement jusqu'au crématorium
alors aigre un peu mon himalaya moi vous
avez pensé inviter johnny ou les stones
pour la première partie n'ont justement
pas de première partie les jurés et vous
allez traverser la foule comme jeanny à
l'idée de givet oui je vais certainement
sur la butte je veux faire un petit tour
certainement de c'est grave c'est de se
faire tuer s'est jouée par 52 mille
personnes c'est non non mais oui je sais
pas plus tard qu'hier un défilé
d'animaux à ce que c'est un peu les
défilés d'animaux avance-t-il arche de
noé avec des gens tous les les animaux
tu sais diddy fond le ski de fond le qui
joue dans les films pathé jamais et où
ferez quoi après le spectacle les champs
elysées en autocar bonnes petites moules
frites
ch
à
je pense